[Music]
in 2018 cyberattacks will affect our
lives like never before
hackers have already compromised
multinational organizations stealing the
personal details of millions hackers
have even been implicated in national
elections and protected against cyber
threats but in 2018 the impact of cyber
criminals will be felt by all 2018 might
be the year where people's attitudes
finally start shifting so not will I be
hacked but when will I be hacked on the
golden shores of Hawaii lives one of the
most prolific hackers on the planet
everybody has hobbies mine's hacking
I've personally hacked just about every
major company and bank on the planet at
one time or another
at the age of 22 Jeremiah Grossman
hacked Yahoo one of the biggest tech
companies in the world in response they
offered him a job Yahoo's chief hacker
there's a vernacular in the industry
there's the white hat hackers and then
there's black hat hackers the way I like
to describe it as kind of like Star Wars
where you have the Jedi and the Sith
these skills are the same but one uses
their powers for good and the other ones
for evil I'm more of the white hat
variety
I use those skills to prevent other
people from getting that there's people
all over the world attacking you and you
have to remain calm and steadfast at
every point because if you lose control
you will lose the battle white hat
hackers break into computer systems to
find the weaknesses and make companies
aware of them but it's about to get even
harder to keep up the defenses the
threats in 2018 will change in terms of
their scale it's the same amount of
effort to hack a million people as it is
hundred million people the bad guys
aren't necessarily innovating they're
scaling with an ever increasing risk to
corporate security 2018 will see an
unlikely Savior in the fight against
hackers insurance companies so next year
I think one big change will be lots more
companies will start taking up cyber
insurance so like any other kind of
insurance if I have home insurance and I
choose to live on a floodplain
it's gonna cost me a lot of money
insurance is not a sexy topic
the reason the hacks keep happening is
not because we don't know how to defend
them that we don't have the right
technology or know-how there's not
always the best motivation for them to
fix the issues in a timely manner people
should care about cyber insurance
because if they're expecting things to
get better if they want organizations to
take this problem seriously insurance
has the best chance of being a lever for
improvement and has incentives so when
an insurance company tells their clients
that you must secure the data like this
that they will or their premiums will
spike that's how it's gonna affect the
everyday person but cyber insurance can
only go so far when we are all becoming
vulnerable to attack more and more of
our everyday lives are being hardwired
to the internet from the lock on our
front door to our heating being
connected may bring convenience but it
also makes our homes and our personal
lives more vulnerable to hackers I think
next year you might start to see it
become a sort of water cooler talking
point the more the hacks happen the more
people get used to the idea that
increasingly everything in the world is
computerized might even start to be a
backlash against this idea and people
saying well do I really need a
computerized fridge do I really need my
toaster talking to the Internet there
was a casino in America recently we've
discovered a big data breach by hacking
into an Internet connected fish tank and
then jumping from there to more
sensitive bits of the network the
companies that aren't taking security
seriously now are going to come to
regret it in the future
the future for the cyber threat beyond
2018 is more than just privacy and
monetary loss before somebody would
break into your bank account or assumed
her identity and steal your money
national transport networks railways
which are controlled by computers now
the signalling systems of the people use
on on motorways and so on a lot of this
infrastructure is is connected to the
Internet
now with connected cars connected energy
grids connected and pacemakers where
everything in life is going to be
connected to the Internet we suffer the
very real risk of loss of life